we can embrace chaos and see that chaos
is the environment in which we all
thrive that's how I've done it for years
you think I could have lived you think I
could have gotten away with this in the
Soviet Union I don't think so I require
a society on the brink of social
breakdown to be able to do my work and
and I think a society on the brink of
social breakdown is the healthiest
situation for individuals I don't know
how many of you have ever had the
privilege of being in a society in a
pre-revolutionary situation but the
cafes stay open all night and there's
music in the streets and you can breathe
it you can feel it and you know what is
happening the Dominator is being pushed
it never succeeds it never it never is
able to claim itself but on the other
hand history is young we may have we may
have a crack at this a global society is
coming into being a global society made
out of information that was not intended
to be ours but which is ours through the
mistaken invention and distribution of
small computers the printing press all
of this stuff information is power and
information has been spilled by the
clumsy handling of the cybernetic
revolution by the Dominator culture in
so that it is everywhere never has the
situation been more fluid never have the
opportunities for infiltration
insurrection and hell-raising been more
present at hand but we have to seize the
opportunity we have to seize the
opportunity because the world doesn't
have that much more to run unless
somebody begins to shake the applecart
if we don't begin to shake the applecart
then the applecart is just going to sail
over the cliff and be lost
you